[Music]
and in self-love news submitted by
everybody lit a journalist was bullied
online after posting selfies Oh
journalist why are we selfie shaming in
2000 I think everyone does selfies was
it he did a myspace angle and they were
great that's old angle that's like all
web it's so that you look like you have
no body stealing shots a extreme like
the forehead yes I like those I like
those too a lot of cleavage I like you
know what cuz you know I think about
like as I get older and like not on 40 I
know you guys aren't my age but the fact
that we all lived before social media
but our kids will only have a their
whole life is social media they'll never
know like not having Twitter
or they know both sides exactly they
were born for phone addicts and we
became business that we invented phone
addiction do you want that for your kids
I want my daughter Jane man I wanted
that's the thing I felt like falling
like in social media and technology I
feel like it takes the the human side
out like even when you like approach a
girl like now you're just sliding in her
dams and saying some [ __ ] like you're
you ads like gather up the nerve to
speak to a woman like you could move to
Papua New Guinea where's that why it's
an island near Indonesia with a bunch of
headhunters leave my head you're a part
of their team you won't lose your head I
think they'll lose just go there and be
like hey same side bro same team because
that's a way to raise them in kind of
like without technology are you guys
always an extreme decision and that's
where you're gonna get your mother I was
sitting there opening my phone the other
day with the I'll tell you the
technology is getting crazier and I'm
like I do what is it gonna be a 50 years
future grandkids cuz I'm like damn
you're so lucky this and try the tech
this is act 2 act 1 was everyone sitting
down watching TV all day right back to
is now we're all addicted off our phones
like this all day and then act 3 will be
in a simulation but that's too far from
the true high right because maybe you
already are the world is gonna go nuts
and like get lit on fire and
everything's gonna be apocalyptic but
then we'll have a VR that makes it all
nature and so it's like I will have like
the sense of nature and we'll think that
we're in nature ready player one or a
big guy things like catastrophe happens
and we reset just like ancient aliens do
cuz we don't know how it happened it
happened there was airports in Egypt if
you look at it there's airports so this
journalist her name is Melissa and she's
a highly accomplished journalist and
writer who she writes essays on
disability relationships and pop culture
sounds not that successful we gentlemen
this is what the article just came well
what does she write for The Wall Street
Journal I'm not gonna get it I don't
know her whole damn resume dr. Jeff
doctor listen so she tweeted anybody
could be a journalist nowadays she
tweeted during the last round of troll
gate people said that I should be banned
from posting photos of myself because
I'm too ugly so I just like to
commemorate the occasion with these
three selfies what the troll games don't
like you what's troll game so well
before I show you the photos oh stop
trying to look what
Oh baby before I show you she does have
a she she is a disabled woman so she was
born with Freeman Sheldon syndrome which
is a genetic condition caused by a
mutation on the gene responsible for
moving substances between cells during
development so she uses a wheelchair and
she has it annulled oils were picking on
like you're ruining it you're supposed
to tell this after I'm just gonna make
fun of her because that it's all about
equal opportunity good man you're
ruining this for me there girl is a good
man right there because you know what
the Equal Opportunity they don't even
care about this then no because I have
to have a heart or at least pretend like
I have a heart right we talk [ __ ] and
then afterwards we go oh that person is
actually dead now I feel bad yeah you're
ruining our brand tip all right
yeah she's so cute oh she just looks
like a baby or like a crow she been find
that crow what's the crowed [ __ ] you
talking about you seen it from your
light nose have you seen a crow I know
oh no sorry she was like she could be in
Harry Potter or something yeah so
they've called her a blobfish
a potato she does look like a blob fish
Oh blob says I can't laugh it which I
can't not laugh it's funny they said I
think I just saw mrs. Potato Head fake
journalist hello Melissa Blake looks
like a blob fish also a perfect example
of a land with so much that her picture
you Melissa Blake is this is the same
tone in every comment a person with
multiple accounts yeah is actually a
potato masquerading as a journalist or
an overweight real-life version of
peppermint patty from the plant that
picture was real and then they said some
other stuff
I think that's his route on me from once
you don't look that bad like that no I
even if you wouldn't even told me that
she had a disease she don't look like
she says she doesn't like a white lady
where I think people were just laying
for doing it she looks like we yeah it's
not even it's like cute weird though
it's not even like ugly weird mm yeah
she's not I would not classify her as
ugly yeah what the [ __ ]
see that's the thing that I think that
social media does that's just a terrible
thing like if this if we didn't have the
technology that we had and she was just
you know some people picture that'd be
such a smaller group of people [ __ ] like
this girl bar we're talking about this
on like her bridge that could be blasted
everywhere so now is just getting
embarrassed on a really really really
big day haircuts not doing any favors of
alright I think it needs to be a little
blown out or something something that
you know widen area cuz yeah it's just a
little too flat for me and the glasses
are a little bit harsh I don't think she
needs those yeah yeah cuz right now the
Dare cuts like um you just got like a
Marc Davis thing going on she's the only
thing I could think of is she looks like
a thong with hair yeah that's all I
could think of what if you gave Orion's
haircut she'd look like a thumb with
right if you put if you put a to happy
face on a thumb like this or a big toe
on your foot and then you put a little
wig like a bowl cut wig are you you know
what no I'm empowering her
[Music]
raise your up video you know hello
patriarchy bull because when you care
about someone you make fun of them it's
endearing right and then on top of that
you want to normalize it by making fun
of them and on top of that I can't help
it because that's what I observe and
that's what I see what Stephen Hawking
look like to you well he's dead now
see what Stephen Hawking but Stephen
Hawking's oh man it's so hard to say
because he's I actually look at people
and I say you look like Stephen Hawking
yeah yeah he's the thing that I compare
to but when I see him hmm
yeah it's hard to say see to me he
looked like you know when you get a you
get a scarecrow for Halloween and then
you're taking a dad for Halloween you
like put it in a chair like when you you
know when you get a good scare core
decoration for Halloween and then you
put it up and then you take it down and
you put it in the chair real quick cause
you're getting off to me it's almost
like you take it like I took it like a
wax figure what Stephen Hawking was and
just think melted a little bit oh yeah
this is the hard-hitting fact that this
is this hits close to home for me when I
see this how the flux you get the blue
check mark on her very very important
publications that people need to know
what I have to say no people need to
confirm that it's action so crazy about
that that's the crazy thing 7 years ago
Instagram didn't it didn't even insist
and nothing about it and now we're on it
was 2010 listen you know we're not that
long ago
and now we care so much about blue
checkmarks look because it's like the
stars upon Mars you know the sneetches
the star belly's peaches you guys ovary
dr. Seuss so it's all about that it's
all about how we place importance on the
stupid [ __ ] so basically there's a star
belly snitches and they're the elite
upper class and all the ones with stuff
that don't have the stars on their
bellies they got it not eat they do not
to not have parties and they ought to be
sad then this guy comes to town he's
like you want to star on your belly
I could put a star on your belly and so
all the poor like non star belly's
teachers are like oh yeah let me have a
star on my belly but then when everybody
got stars on their bellies this messy
originalist our bellies seniors are like
well now we want ours off of our bellies
so the guy is like I could take yours
off your belly and so it becomes this
whole thing we're like they can't
remember who was elite and not elite
because they keep trying to separate
themselves and then they get all mixed
up in the winner here
the star belly mass so what you're tired
that we need to exploit people's
insecurities about themselves and make a
[ __ ] ton of money the snitches this
nieces because of this video because of
me and Joe being good people this lady
won't employ a hairdresser and I think
that that's important I think she's cute
and I start with the [ __ ] so I can
talk about her circle they're so
innocent that circus a Regis I find that
very cute I just think we can do the zoo
some with hair yeah they're so duster I
think she's cute she's my color doesn't
really do anything
check marks that's what it is yeah yeah
they can't wait to give me journalists
man I'm just jealous cuz she's way more
famous than I am
no so where's he gonna stop posing the
selfies no she breaks three why she's so
dope throw on a battery not in person
the world needs more of
[Music]